um let's go today to
our caller from the two five zero area
code who's calling today from two five
zero
hey david my name is ashley not calling
from um
i'm actually calling from canada i'm not
from victoria i'm not sure
you know where that is it's just a
couple hours north of seattle
okay a couple hours north of seattle
what's going on today
um i should have a quick question for
you i don't know how quick it is
actually but
um so i think that you're probably aware
too that like
the the eviction crisis is going over
pretty soon here probably in the next
couple months if not the next month yes
and i was wondering what you think
of uh strategically withholding
rent as a tactic and how do you think
that would pan out in the us
or how effective do you think that would
be so i've actually i'm glad you're
asking this i've talked about
you know i've done a bunch of segments
and there's one in particular about
types of activism where i've said you
know calling your representatives is
great
um signing petitions online i don't
think it really does anything
but the activism tactics that may get
more attention would be
mass rallies in urban centers strategic
defaults
uh of of debt of different kinds which
could include
coordinated non-payment of mortgages
coordinated non-payment of rent
etc um i i think the complexity right
now is
it wouldn't just be activism like
there's
32 percent of people were unable to pay
their entire mortgage
or rent on july 1st so what we're
talking about is
an actual economic crisis in which a
third of the country wasn't able to
fully make their july 1st payments
and then adding on top of that another
element of this happening
strategically during a time when there
may be an extended eviction moratorium
or there may not
it's unclear they're talking about it
but it's not clear a deal is actually
going to get done
so it's extremely speculative what would
happen in this particular case
the idea for people to understand of
saying
nobody pay your mortgages nobody pay
your rent is that if
everybody really did it and of course
everybody would never do it there's a
huge part of society that would say
i'm fine i'm not going to get involved
in this i'm not going to hurt my credit
or whatever but if a large enough
portion of society withheld mortgage and
rent payments
you would instantly [ __ ] the
financial industry with a massive
liquidity crisis
it would probably force the government
to have to in the short term
put in a crazy amount of money to keep
these financial institutions afloat and
the idea would be it would bring
stakeholders to the table to actually
negotiate some of the change that
people people want now agreeing on what
the change people want
is is a whole other issue and brings
complexity but it's an interesting idea
i don't know what
adding a strategic default on top of an
existing
eviction and foreclosure crisis would
would really do a potential one
uh but it's a it's a very interesting
question
yeah um i think like uh quickly like i
think you would
you would pan out a lot worse in canada
where there is a little bit more of a
social net for people
but i think in america i think where i
don't know if the social net is quite
there so this kind of i think the the
the view on it would be a little more
positive in certain places versus other
places right so that's why i was asking
you how you thought it would have been
out of the u.s but yeah i i
really appreciate this one i mean listen
if it happened if you had a
significantly coordinated mortgage and
rent default in the united states
it would immediately become
hyper-politicized where
it would be you know attacked by the
right
as just grifter lazy people on the left
who don't want to pay their bills and so
on and so forth
the left would likely hail them as doing
something really good in order to
inspire change potentially at their own
uh economic peril and it would become
honestly just like everything else where
it would become hyper partisan
and i don't know how far we would get
with it unfortunately
yeah fair enough i agree with you there
yeah all right my friend thank you for
the call very interesting question i
appreciate it